[Music]
thank you
so on on this one
don't go for the wrist
uh it's kazushi first so could you see
if you want that notebook
the elbow the elbow
elbow if you pay attention
uh my time entering while his arm was
still
in the position so I'm not here
waiting and then trying to protect his
wrist
uh slower you guys look do you see the
Yin
that's when I enter okay so I'm not in
train ways he goes y'all that's not what
I'm doing okay so when he goes oh that
is when I mean
I'm on the elbow elbow
um
[Music]
album
slow down a little so uh you're gonna do
it as if I was there go slow okay so
there there's the Yin
and then I've already started entering
and he goes
and you see it has fist raise there it's
about an inch okay
that is where I am now on the album so
when he goes to lift that friction
between my movement and your intention
of that lift that's what I now project
into the survival
okay it's not that I grab him okay
so again we'll we'll watch it go really
slow there's the yes I've already
started entering and I am going to do my
10 con
where this hand
is in the inward spiral
you've seen so I can't do it here it was
trial is it in front of me this is where
I do the movement
so common mistakes are
uh you go way past the guy you see a way
way past your guy like that you don't
you can't push a weight on here but way
back here this is this is where your
weight is okay or another one
is uh you're trying to grab it you're
trying to grab it
instead of using the energetic
connection right or we already went
you're on the wrist and you're trying to
grab it right or you're trying to take
it out
okay so pay attention how how I'm doing
that and you can feel it's with your
foreign
[Music]
but if you pay attention
there's the inward outward and then the
movement it's it's quick okay but it's
from uh uh so you'll have your inwards
you see
people Inward and then they're here
or your chat
let me go a little slower a little
smoother and you'll see it one two three
we could gradually
pick it up
or just here
it's first covered cover low double
doctor on the Low cover covers
cover a little
here
[Music]
okay
so once you have that position
uh you go into there's just certain
things you have to do okay so uh
so the first one is that he has to try
to come up okay because you might drop
someone solo that he'll change levels
and come in this space that's not
perfect okay the guy has to come up
rule number one okay
boom he comes up rule number two
uh he cannot come around if you go in
the front of him you have to stay in the
back of him okay so
um I'm here he goes down he comes back
up I might have to do another test on to
stay in the back of him
there's no real rule on that of on how
you do it but you have to stay in the
back of him okay
uh so we've got it again
bold comes up I move again and I stay in
the back again okay rules three uh you
don't want slacking here
can be no slack in here okay so as you
do the throw that has you have to be in
his body
okay
boom like his body
this one
okay we'll try it and I don't want to
cover it so much but those three
principles all right try
here we go
I I in order to address him coming up he
has to go forward just like uh
uh
so when he comes up it's not that I'm
cranking
he comes up and I bring It Forward
otherwise don't and he will regain his
balance okay so here it comes up I think
I go forward okay now what I want you to
look for go back one there you go okay
it's this angle
this is the angle I want because when we
when our style we take when we do the
throw we're going to take the bass
okay I don't need to take the base off
tonight but I I want you to thumbs up
and you're looking here and see it's
right we're kind of like sideways
but I'm in the back
so when I when I do the code that I ask
with his arm my leg comes in here boom
and to do that you really have to have
them come forward
so we're gonna change the ending
so
boom here we go
so you get that
powder
[Music]
okay okay
you can see I'm still opening uh
[Music]
okay so she strikes
oh thumbs up look how I say always in
the back you see
oh yeah
foreign
always
inside
okay try it again it shouldn't have been
visible when on the last
instruction but we're going to point it
out okay so
come around
here and bring him forward
I don't want his elbow to go from my
right to my left
his elbow is going to stay
pretty much on my Center Line okay and
as I move
it moves on that sentiment
so if you come over there I'll do that
again
right I don't want to go here and go and
come left to right okay that doesn't
work
instead his elbow might even come on my
body and I'm going to move myself to the
other side of it you see that's right
so we're gonna do that the same drill
right here you can see that
we're gonna do that again you're gonna
have to get on that side
okay
now I'm going around
good
because what I'm trying to do is take
away
stress from
from okay you can't can't use your hands
to flip a human body okay that's gonna
work okay so something similar to this
is uh
let's
tell I'm going to do I'm gonna do uh
so instead of doing Nico like this
you see and I had to use that strength
I'll move
in a way you see that this
turn because of how I move my body
Okay so
uh still not quite at the throne
but getting there oh
I'm not taking his base out yet
hey then later if I see
that I'm going around this
for the purposes
of getting in there
I'm pulling on it it's gonna plant my
feet
okay
leave the leg check out
rule number two was no slack no no rule
number three was no slack no slack in
the arm okay
so as he's going
and you uh move the arm left to right
that's that's a lot of slack you can do
some things but this this way it stays
in his body and I stay uh in my body
with his body okay now you got here if
you know I'll ease up a little
if you open it it's gonna be slack that
the no slack is here you see and it gets
taken in the ark
as in a dilemma with the base do you see
that so
I I start displacing the base to not
have to pull you so I displace all right
to do it okay you can't do one or the
other
and it changes from time to time
okay so if you pay attention how many
right angles do I have come back up
right angle
right angle right angle you see and that
thing's cranking around
and that's only because we want uh the
back of his head to head if you wanted a
different result you could loosen up
the key is
you hiding back here
okay